on va répondre à plusieurs de vos
questions ce soir il y aura des
nouvelles également dans l'émission mais
surtout des questions et des réponses
avec nous marianne plamondon avocate
spécialisée en droit du travail et luc
godbout titulaire de la chaire de
recherche en fiscalité et finances
publiques de l'université de sherbrooke
bonsoir à vous deux
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous pour
répondre comme ça à des questions d'ici
la fin de l'émission va commencer tout
de suite parce qu'on a quelques minutes
avant la prochaine pause commerciale
on y va marianne plamondon d'abord
quatre viendra-t-il des personnes qui
n'ont pas travaillé suffisamment
d'heures pour être éligible au chômage
alors ces gens là vont tomber le sou la
location le de soins d'urgence prévues
dans le plan d'intervention fédéral qui
prévoit 900 $ pour deux semaines et qui
sillonnera pour un 15 semaines
notons que cette allocation là
s'applique également aux travailleurs
autonomes
donc ce sera à voir le
à faire la demande le plus rapidement
possible le godbout quelque chose à
ajouter là dessus ceux qui perdent leur
emploi là il ya également la location de
soutien d'urgence qui est également
offert et allocation là aussi s'offrent
aux travailleurs autonomes donc deux
allocations ce pour les gens malades qui
doivent rester à la maison sont en
quarantaine ou qui s'occupent d'un
proche et ceux qui perdent leur emploi
deux allocations en parallèle les deux
les paramètres vont être connu au début
d'avril le pouvoir attend ça c'est au
début d'avril parce qu'on sait que ça a
été annoncé cette semaine mais c'est au
début d'avril qu'on aura tous les
détails pour aller de l'avant avec sa
deuxième question je suis travailleuse
autonome est ce que j'ai droit aux
délais de paiement autant pour mes
impôts que pour la tps tvq à remettre au
30 avril luc godbout
alors pour une travailleuse autonome on
sait déjà que la production de la
déclaration d'impôt sur le revenu
la date limite n'était pas le 30 avril
pour eux il y avait droit jusqu'au 15
juin
cette date le 15 juin n'est pas changé
par contre pour le paiement de l'impôt
comme pour le contribuable ordinaire la
date est repoussée au 1er septembre
là je tiens précision on parle d'impôt
sur le revenu du québec et d'ottawa
mais lorsqu'on produit la déclaration
d'impôt sur le revenu du québec on paie
en même temps pour un travailleur
autonome
les cotisations au régime des rentes du
québec les cotisations régime québécois
d'assurance parentale le fonds des
services de santé
ici on n'a pas d'assurance privée on
paye également l'assurance médicaments
du québec tous à ces paiements là
lorsqu'on fait la déclaration c'est
également repoussée au 1er septembre
par contre à venir jusqu'à maintenant la
tps tvq qu'on prélève sur les ventes et
on doit le remettre à la date qui était
prévu initialement il ya pas eu de
report pour remettre la taxe cette taxe
la partie un gouvernement normalement
voilà depuis de report de deux peuples a
pas de changement de ce côté là on y va
avec une autre qu'arrive-t-il pour ceux
qui ont déjà de l'assurance emploi
depuis quelques mois et dont il ne reste
que quelques semaines tout au plus avant
la fin des prestations marianne
flamandes ont alors lu
quand le plan d'intervention fédéral
vont être mis en place le complètement
on dit début avril ils pourront toucher
l'allocation de soins d'urgence qui
permet d'avoir le 902 leur part maximum
900 $ pour deux semaines pour une autre
durée de 15 semaines
donc ce sera le programme qui sera le
plus adéquat autrement évidemment si
jamais ne se qualifie pas aux conditions
qui vont être mis sur pied pour ce
programme là ils pourront toujours aller
sur l'aide sociale très bien on a le
temps pour une dernière question avant
la pause mais patrons veulent baisser
nos salaires sans garantie de retrouver
notre taux horaire après la crise
est-ce que c'est acceptable évidemment
il ya beaucoup d'employeurs à l'heure
actuelle qui se posent cette question là
savoir est ce qu on devrait diminuer les
salaires
gardez en tête que si c'est plus de 15 %
de diminution de salaire on tombe dans
la catégorie des congères congédiement
déguisé en vertu de la jurisprudence
donc si on étend congédiement déguisé à
ce moment là ça fait naître toutes
sortes de nouvelles obligations pour les
employeurs donc si on pense à une
réduction de salaire faut garder ça en
mode 15% de modification sinon les
employés vont avoir le droit de réclamer
une indemnité de fin d'emploi en disant
qu'ils ont été congédié de façon
déguisée avec une modification
substantielle de leurs conditions
d'emploi attention attention c'est
important vous restez avec nous marianne
clamant dont le godbout vous êtes là
vous allez répondre à d'autres questions
marzo l'instant